- Oh.
Shit.
(light music)
- Mustaches.
- [Both] Lady mustaches.
Not often talked about
but often ripped off violently.
- Why don't we talk
about our lady mustaches?
- I don't know.
- Well, we surveyed the
women of the Buzzfeed office
and found that 77 percent of them
are self conscious
about their facial hair.
- And 85 percent of them
say that their mustache
is their worst enemy.
- Yep and we are a part
of that 85 percent.
- [Voiceover] Waxing is
the most popular form
of mustache murder with about
40 percent of the office
preferring to wax it off
as opposed to any other method.
- So we decided to turn handlebar homicide
into lady bonding time
and we're going to wax
each others' mustaches.
- Because it can't be that hard.
- So what's up with waxing?
- I know I spend a good amount of money
getting my mustache waxed
amongst other things that I wax.
- But could I not just do it myself?
- It's Ladylike and today
we're waxing our mustaches.
- I'm bitchybrows
I am a licensed esthetician
and I specialize in brow shaping
and waxing for both men and women.
- Kelsey's going to wax my mustache.
- I don't know why you're
trusting me to do this.
- I've never waxed it before
because I never felt this huge need to.
- I'm putting my stache in Nikki's hands.
- I don't like being out of control
so this is going to be a new experience.
I don't like it.
Okay.
- We are going to cleanse it,
remove all the oil, residue and cosmetics.
It's always good just to get
in and around the mouth.
- Do you trust me?
- You seem very thorough at this point.
- So go ahead and apply this
on her right side of her upper lip.
- Stop moving.
- [Voiceover] And just smooth it down
just like frosting on a cake.
Smooth it all the way down.
This is where it gets a little bit scary.
Now, apply the waxing
strip on top of the wax.
- [Voiceover] I'll fold you, girl.
- Alright, that's good.
Not too hard.
You don't want to apply it too hard
because then you'll have a higher--
- Will it rip her face off?
- You might rip her skin off.
- [Voiceover] Okay, ready?
One, two.
- Oh.
- Ah.
- Ugh.
- Ooh.
- You're kind of bleeding.
- I'm bleeding?
- [Voiceover] There's not a lot.
It's a little bit.
- Oh.
- Ah.
- Ooh.
- Bitch.
(laughing)
- This is one of the
more sensitive areas too
because you have the most nerve endings
at the Cupid's Bow.
- So many sides to a mustache.
- Middle usually hurts the worst.
- Ooh.
- Oh.
- How did that happen?
- Yeah.
There's a lot of hair on there.
- So much hair.
- Ooh.
- There they are.
The little blondies.
- [Voiceover] This is very therapeutic.
- So we're going to go
ahead and use this oil.
- And just all over?
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- Look at you ready to
take on the world staches.
- [Eva] Now we're going to go ahead
and apply the soothing gel.
- I feel both scared and
also secure in your hands.
- Yes.
I mean sure, the hairlessness is fine
but that was a lot of to do
for a couple little hairs.
- Do you feel good?
- I feel great.
- I really like the friend aspect
of doing each others' mustaches.
It made me feel more comfortable
even though she'd never done it before.
- This is probably the thing
I've been the most embarrassed about
to put online
is literally my mustache.
- It's a very real thing
that I think every female relates to.
Very natural to have peach fuzz.
- Would you guys do this again?
Should we all hang out
and have a waxing party?
- I'm so into that idea.
- Yeah.
I thought it was fun.
- It was a good bonding moment.
It brought us closer together.
I trust you now.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Because I didn't before.
- Eva taught us well.
- What else could we wax?
- Vages.
- What could we wax next?
- Consensus, vaginas.
Tune in later.
- Yeah, I want my vag waxed.
I want to feel what that feels like.